you're in this job you hate and it's 10
years from now
how does that look think about that you
already know you're in a little hell
you know perfectly well it's going to
get worse which is more frightening
action or inaction
dr jordan peterson welcome to the show
hi chris thanks for the invitation have
you got bored of
people telling you that they're glad
you're back yet no
you i think you'd have to be foolish to
be bored about that i mean
i don't ever want to get to the point
where i take people's
sincere well wishes uh you know casually
i'm always stunned and grateful that
people
care and so no it's definitely not
and i'm surprised that i'm seem to be
moving towards some health and so
no definitely not i'll add another one
to the list i'm glad that you're back
thank you thank you i'm i'm looking
forward to this
to to to being back and to doing all the
things that are
in front of me that i could do if i was
healthy so
we so we what's the story with you
and red skull
well i don't know i mean i came across
this last week and
and someone tweeted me this this cartoon
this comic
captain america comic and
i saw this screenshot of red skull
looking at a
computer screen and it said ten rules
for life
that was one text box it said order and
chaos
and there was a couple of other boxes
and i thought well that seems to be
making a reference to my work i mean 10
rules for life is
pretty close to 12 rules for life and of
course the main themes i discuss are
order and chaos
i mean one book is about order and the
other is about chaos and my first book
is about both so
as a joke you know associating my ideas
with
this arch villain magic super nazi
red skull and then as i looked into it
more deeply
and as people sent me more information
it became clear that
at least some of the inspiration
for this red skull character in this
captain america
uh variant was appeared to be
targeting let's say or satirizing or
warning about
my ideas and so i've been playing with
that ever since i suppose on twitter
people are producing memes now of red
skull
oh superimposed upon the picture of him
things i've actually said instead of the
hypothetical things that the people who
don't like me wish i said and then
purposefully misinterpret
and so that's that and uh
it's i'm trying to make it into
something playful
it's so absurd it shocked me to begin
with i couldn't believe it
to begin with it especially when i found
out who the author of the comic book was
so um you know he's uh intellectual
figure
among the leftist community uh
relatively well known
um and politically correct and
i i didn't expect it it it really threw
me for a loop to begin with
i mean it's really something to see
yourself portrayed
let's say parodied satirized um
as a i've been called a nazi before it's
not pleasant but
this is one step beyond that i mean
nazi apparently isn't enough i have to
be a magical super nazi
and you know by implication well really
it's so it's so
it's so surreal and absurd that that i
couldn't believe
it to begin with and it and then i think
what's happening with it is so comical
because red skull is a demonic character
i mean he's a satanic character and
in his looks and in his actions and
people are putting my words over his
representation and there's a jarring
discontinuity between the visual image
and the actual words especially for the
quotes that have been derived from my
talks that are in some
sense more straightforward and and
commonsensical
like you know clean up your room or
or don't lie um they're not exactly the
sorts of messages that
the most malevolent imaginable nazi
super villain would dream up and
promulgate
so i think we're doing a
t-shirt based on this image a kid
developed in eastern europe which is a
variant of the hail hydra logo
except it's transformed into a lobster
we're going to market a limited edition
poster and then donate all the proceeds
to charity
that's that's today's plan that should
be launched by
tomorrow so that'd be what's today's
thursday april
what is it today 11th or so
i don't even know what date it is april
8th it is
the 8th so yeah i think that'll be up on
the 9th or 10th of april
so well if i'm playing with it if that's
not turning chaos into order i don't
know what is
well it's kind of an interesting
challenge you know and and
when because i've been so ill it's been
very difficult for me to maintain my
sense of humor which is a terrible loss
um you know it's the best response to
that sort of thing is
is a deft play you know rather than
than outrage even though it it is
outrageous
it's it's outrageous to the point of
being surreal and
that's partly why it was so shocking to
me i couldn't believe that that could
possibly be
real but there was you know and
many people who fancy themselves as my
enemies
have pointed out that well i'm probably
so much like
this red skull character that i'm just
imagining that it's a parody of my ideas
but
i'm afraid that's a pretty weak argument
given the
you know virtual word for word
similarity of ten rules for life and
chaos and order no
that's not a coincidence sorry we can
just add it to the list of weird things
that's happened over the last 18 months
or so that you've now ended up in a
marvel comic
yeah well it's like a weird thing seems
i i don't know
yes my life seems to predictably consist
of
unpredictably weird things and i don't
really know what to make of that
and neither my family as well because it
tends to throw them for a loop as well
although my daughter at the moment is
having some fun playing with this
she's also healthy enough to have
regained her sense of humor so
she's quite enthusiastic about the
opportunity that this
lays out but it is quite interesting
that well it's i guess it's an
indication too of the
the affordances provided by this new
technology
you can respond everyone can now respond
you know for so long
have access to broad scale media meant
that you were a corporation and
generally a very rich one
and now everyone has that at their
fingertips and it's and it's a whole new
world
like so new it's so different no one
knows what to make of it everyone's a tv
producer everyone's a radio host it's
stunning
it's stunning i've been looking at tik
tok lately um
you know because i try to investigate
all these social media forms as they
arise because
while i'm interested in communicating
with people and i'm curious about the
technologies and
one of the things i've seen on tick talk
is there'll be a
a video clip say of something i said
uh something went viral and tick tock
the other day i was talking to my
daughter about this study that
indicated that for every 15 points
in iq a woman gains over a hundred her
probability of being married declines by
about 30 percent and the opposite is
true for men
and so that's only
about a 60-second video which is par for
the course for tick-tock but
then people are pairing it with a video
of someone listening to that and
reacting to it and so
all of a sudden you have this
possibility for dialogue in video
and that's a you know that's that's
never been the case so what does that
mean well god only knows it's a whole
it's a whole new means of broad-scale
communication it's two-way video two-way
permanent video
with no bureaucratic infra interference
so
it it radically levels the media playing
field
it and and you can see and i see this so
interesting too that
the legacy media uh types are
they're done they're so done it's it's
happened so fast
i noticed among young people that the
legacy media
the big magazines the newspapers the tv
stations the radio stations for that
matter
all of whom had a monopoly on this kind
of information flow
are so dead to people under 30 that it's
as if
their death isn't even noticed and
that's fascinating and yesterday
i i interviewed richard trombley and
richard trombley is a is in his 80s and
he's a scientist who studied
male aggression a research scientist who
studied male and female aggression for
40 years
and he's one that criminologists
equivalent of the nobel prize and the
order of canada which is canada's
knighthood for all intents and purposes
um hundreds of publications a very
distinguished scientist and
we had a two-hour conversation and i
thought afterwards i thought you know
i've only been able to have
conversations like that
in graduate seminars in the highest
quality graduate seminars
in the most elite universities now and
then
even though i was pleased to have those
conversations two hours on a single
topic
covered in as much depth as possible um
by someone who's a world authority and
now i can have that conversation with
people
and 150 000 to a million people
can have access to it instantly it's
like i think
god only knows what that is going to be
the consequence of that
so it's so fun to to play around with
this and to experiment with it and
and it's such a privilege to be able to
do it and there's so much possibility in
it so
and i've also been trying to figure out
what i'm doing with the podcasts
themselves because that's really what
i've been
doing a lot of for the last four months
and i listened to this
i was interviewed by a wall street
journalist last week
and i asked him what he liked about
podcast because he listened to them a
lot and he said i really like to see
where they're going
and i thought yeah that's exactly it
because in a
legacy media interview everything is
scripted and you're never talking to a
person you're talking to the
corporation essentially and i'm not
being cynical about that
it had to be that way because bandwidth
was so expensive
but now you can sit down with someone
and you can risk exploration of course
that's what joe rogan has been doing so
well for so many years you can risk
exploration
you can have two people having a genuine
discussion about a complex issue and so
they're they're engaging in dialectical
thinking and if they're good at it
they're modeling it
so they can model high quality
dialectical thinking
and pull people along on an exploratory
journey
and make it permanent and that's
completely revolutionary that's never
been possible before
and and and the possibilities are
um limitless and then sorry i'm going to
rant about this a bit because i i am so
continually staggered by this the next
thing is you can take those
conversations
and you can chop them up into 30 second
pieces of minute long pieces five minute
long pieces
20 minute long pieces and each of those
can find a specialized home
that can attract millions of views and
so
it's as if you could write a book and
sell it by the sentence
it's it's really something so well so
that's
you know all response to red skull i
suppose
the interesting thing that i think i
enjoy about podcasts and a lot of
audiences do as well is that unscripted
nature but it's not just the fact that
the topics are unscripted
it's the the cadence and the the timbre
of the the tone of the way that the
conversation flows as well
if you struggle to work something out if
you're battling
at the forefront of your own cognitive
capacity to try and
get something from brain to mouth we get
to hear
i'm brought along and where it's almost
like a football match or a sports game
we're willing the person to get to the
goal
absolutely yep it is exactly like that
it's a
it it it it's it's a you're the analogy
is
directly appropriate that's why people
like football and soccer games look
those
they the players are trying to put
something into the goal
well that's what you're doing when
you're having a genuine dialogue
you know it isn't necessarily clear what
the goal is
it's more implicit because you're you're
starting to make that more and more
clear too
but but and and there is something
engaging about participating in that
apparently
as a listener as well as a participant
and i can tell perfectly well
when a podcast discussion is going well
and it's a dance
right i mean there's there has to be
this continual reciprocity and
that requires you to attend very
carefully to your guest
and to listen i have some trouble with
not interrupting because
for a variety of reasons but some of
that's the technological lag produced by
the
by zoom and skype it makes you a little
less uh
what the dance is a little more awkward
because the timing is off
but it's it's really fun when it works
and
it's working much of the time when i'm
talking to my guests
it's really exciting
i have all sorts of people lined up i'm
so excited about it
yeah yeah long may it continue i really
do think that it's
it's such an answer to so much bad media
and bad thinking
and it gives a platform to people who
can't hide behind
media training anything and script can't
hide behind anything no there is no play
style i don't think
i think no there's no place to hide i
think that if in two hours you reveal
your hand
and everyone can see it you reveal the
weaknesses and strengths of your
argument you reveal the weaknesses and
strengths of your character
you know but but in some sense you can
even if your character
is flawed like all of our characters are
you know if you're engaged in something
genuine
and in a genuine move forward you're
forgiven for that
right it is if you're if you're actively
rectifying your evident flaws during the
discussion people will forgive you for
your flaws but
youtube and podcast long form seems
absolutely unforgiving of
any falsity as far as i can tell i mean
sometimes we do some editing
there's two conditions under which we'll
edit one is just to edit out some
technical
glitch we also allow our guests
the option of not having something they
said broadcast
if they believe they've made a factual
error or addressed an argument
in a misleading way and that's a little
bit more of a moral quagmire but our
thought is that
if we allow people that veto power to
begin with they're much
more likely to be loose and to take
risks
in the exploration and we've had to cut
virtually nothing except
i think two factual errors of a few
seconds but
it's so interesting because in the
comments section if we ever edit
anything
there's skepticism right away and so
and so that's another indication of how
unforgiving
the medium is with regards to falsity
i'm trying to get politicians on my
podcast i senator mike lee who's
probably the most conservative senator
in the united states the i'm releasing a
podcast with him this weekend and i
think he acquitted himself well
um and i'm hoping that i'm i'm i've been
in contact with a large number of
democrats
and i'm hoping that they'll take the big
leap because they can talk
directly to their constituents
they can talk directly to the people who
they're responsible to
with no intermediation of bureaucracy
if they dare that's that's the thing
because when it's unedited
when it's a flowing conversation for a
long amount of time
the precipice on either side you are
walking a tightrope as you said
there is no opportunity to go away and
check what you actually want to say and
rewrite it in a script it is
riding the crest of now constantly
surfing the wave of the crest of now um
i think it's going to find out who
it's a genuineness
test like a canary in the coal mine for
how genuine someone is
because there's no way that you can hold
up a persona for two hours straight
yeah well or or or maybe somewhat more
forgiving than that it might be a canary
test for how genuine
they're they're attempting to move
towards
because like i said i think you can make
mistakes but
but but if if you're
bargaining in good faith the audience
will forgive you
for your for your mistakes so but but
you're punished brutally if you're false
so and i don't know about you but i'm
really attentive to the comments i watch
how people are responding and
you know if 10 people point out
something i'm still working on this
proclivity to interrupt but
if 10 people point out something i try
to address it my team tries to address
it because
well why not you know i mean you're
probably doing something wrong
at some point and enough people will
tell you it's tricky
but it's at least worth considering
it it's really exciting moving on to the
book your new book is about the excesses
of order
i've been thinking a lot about the
perils of over-optimization for the
individual so
as you sink into the productivity in the
personal development world
it can lead to never feeling like you're
done
alan watts has this quote where he says
we can become so consumed with trying to
improve our lives
that we all together forget to live them
is there a way that people can learn to
let go of this compulsion a little bit
that that's a really good question um
i think my my second book
implicitly answers some of that
um and explicitly some of it as well but
the implicit
part is there's an increased emphasis on
social ties
and so for me i
snap out of the improvement slash
productivity
trap to the degree that i'm able when
i'm
playing with my family let's say when
we're joking when we're sitting around
a meal time together when when there's
peace there and we can joke and play
and i'm trying as particularly as i'm
trying to regain my health i'm trying to
really rekindle that capacity to play
and enjoy the moment even if i'm not
doing something
productive in and that
that's a very difficult balance to
attain optimally
like any optimal balance is difficult to
attain um
you know it isn't obvious to me how much
of i have no idea
the the multiple sources of my health
troubles i was diagnosed this month with
severe sleep central sleep apnea and so
that was a great relief because i have a
machine now so i breathe properly i was
waking up
uh 25 times an hour apparently my sleep
was
so i was getting no restorative sleep
and so
that was one contrib major contributor
and since i've been
breathing at night i've actually been
feeling quite a bit better
unsurprisingly
but i've been scouring my conscience to
determine
if you have an undiagnosed illness
especially if it's severe
it's very likely that you're going to
tear
yourself apart looking for what you did
wrong
to have this arise and
you know i think that
it so i've been considering did i
take on too much responsibility did i
work too much
et cetera et cetera i don't know the
answer to that yet
but what i do know is that since i've
been trying to regain my health
i've been doing a lot of walking and
that's been really good and i'm not
working while i'm walking i'm walking
and
i've been working out more and i've been
playing more and i've been dancing more
and that's all useful and that has to be
balanced with that productivity
because what you're looking for a you're
looking for improvement but you're
looking for sustainable
improvement and so if you push yourself
too hard you
you destroy the sustainability across
time
and and you want that sustainability
there so you can't push yourself any
farther than you're capable of
going in the long run i found for
example
because i've written diligently
for a long time daily and i learned
quite early on that
writing more than three hours in a day
was counterproductive
whatever i gained from a four-hour
writing session i'd lose the next day or
two
so but i also think you have to kind of
push yourself past your limits
before you can retract to the optimal
place
and that can't be sort of defined a
priori because each person's
limit is different and i think so i
think what you do when you're young in
your 20s if you're
perhaps if you're operating in an
optimal manner is you push yourself to
your limits and then
pull back and adjust for sustainability
and i helped lots of people do that in
my clinical practice like i worked with
lawyers who were at the pinnacle of
their profession
and the demands on them are incredible
they're working 60 to 80 hours a week
um generally what i did with them was
get them to take more days off they
couldn't work shorter days but they
could plan
four day weekends two months in advance
and they could do that every two months
then inevitably if they did that the
number of billable hours they produced
went up
not down so they maybe doubled their
vacation time and
increased their productivity so it was a
really good deal for them
they got their cake and eat it too they
got to have their cake and eat it too
so do we lean to need to learn to play
in a way
play can be uh we need to remember how
we all know right i mean play is so
deeply embedded in human beings it's
it's one of our primary modes of of of
cognition and
adaptation mammals have a specialized
play circuit that's
that's that's it's biologically
what would you say specialized precisely
for play
and so and it's an interesting circuit
because
a lot of this has been discovered by
people who study animal behavior
especially among rats but
play in rats produces prefrontal lobe
development
and that's the highest that's the part
of the brain that's responsible for
highest order cognition
so rats have to play a lot to mature
properly and they play
socially and social play is social
integration
there's no difference between the
ability to play socially and being
socially integrated
um like a good conversation at
dinner time is a form of play because
there's wit involved and there's banter
and there's timing and there's a dance
and there's
you know there's the matching of your
physical responses to the physical
response of the other person
it's it's play but play is very easily
inhibited by almost any other
motivational state
and so you can also tell that if you can
get yourself into a playful mood that
that you're in an optimal place
otherwise you wouldn't be able to do it
so it's a good sign that things are
going right
in rule two you say to imagine who we
could be and
then to aim single-mindedly at that but
reality gets in the way of you reaching
that potential
and it can hurt how can
people cope with the pain of unreached
potential
well part of oh that's a really good
question look
every ideal is a judge
right so you posit an ideal and
instantly you're in inferior position in
relationship to that ideal and that can
be crushing
okay so what do you do about that well
one answer is no ideals
well that's not a good answer because
then you don't have anything to do
right so so and that deprives you of a
main source of pleasure which is
observed uh generated as a consequence
of observed movement towards a valued
goal so
if you have a high goal and you see any
movement towards it there's a potential
there's a really powerful potential kick
there so you don't want to dispense with
that
but then if you set up an ideal it can
judge you very harshly
so then you have to rearrange your
reward
philosophy and instead of punishing
yourself from
as a consequence of perceived distance
you reward yourself for incremental
movement forward
and that's not just theoretical look i
was stopped by three guys on the street
this week
three separate occasions and they all
told me the same thing they you know
they
they said that they had read or
something i wrote or listened to
something
or watched something and that it had
been helpful and whenever
ever anybody says that to me i always
ask them okay exactly what
was helpful and what changed because i
want to know what's helping
so that i can understand the target and
hit it better
and so and generally people are are
pleased to tell me
although sometimes it takes them a while
to formulate exactly the description
but they all three of them said um i
stopped comparing myself
to other people so i'll stop comparing
what i didn't have to what other people
had i left that off the table
and then i started to reward myself for
improving over what i was
yesterday so they and that's profound
change because it means that you
actually get
your reward structure transformed
and that's a big deal because that's
that's your source of positive
emotion and enthusiasm encouragement all
of that so now you can start to
encourage yourself for
for genuine improvement and it's also
pragmatically extremely intelligent
because
incremental improvement repeated is
virtually unstoppable
and i that's like the hallmark of
behavioral therapy
that idea because what a behavior
therapist does is you come and you say
to me i'm not things aren't the way i
want them to be
and then i say well well how would you
like them to be
and how are they not that so we lay out
the problem the territory
and then the next thing we do is lay out
a trajectory which is okay well here's
something
you're lonesome you don't have a partner
okay so what are the what are
incremental movements can you make
towards that goal
that you would do that would be helpful
and so maybe you you you negotiate with
the person
because that's what you do if you're a
reasonable therapist and you say well
look why don't you uh
you decide as a consequence of the
conversation why don't you write out a
description of yourself for a dating
site don't post it or anything
just write it out and and then let's see
if you actually do that
and so then the person comes back next
week and they say i did that and
not only that i posted it and you say
great what's the next step or they say
geez you know i just kept avoiding that
and then you say okay well we need to
break that down
you avoided it well could you write one
sentence about who you are
right now while you're sitting here and
sometimes they can do that
right away or sometimes they can't and
then you you make a microanalysis of
that
and what you do is you you reduce
the magnitude of the move forward
until you hit the point where you
actually will do it
and that's like the secret to good
negotiation and as well
if you're negotiating with your wife
maybe you want one of her behaviors to
change
and then obviously she has to be on
board with that and
hypothetically that's going to be
reciprocal process
but what you want to do is find a small
improvement that is measurable
that's implementable that will be
implemented that you can then reward
and and that's that's that's how you can
have your ideal
you you can have whatever ideal you want
as long as you're willing
to reduce your movement forward to
achievable increments
but that's okay because they compound
so and i really learned this as a
therapist it was one of the things that
was so fun about being a therapist is
you can take someone through this
process and start them on just the
tiniest goal you know and
it just seems trivial but they'll do it
and then
they start moving fast aft faster and
faster after that point once
once the direction has been established
and people make incredible improvement
over
you know not unreasonable spans of time
a few months maybe a few years but which
is not nothing but it's not
decades you know it's i saw that time
and time again
so aim high but
reward yourself for small incremental
improvements especially ones that repeat
every day i think that's one of the
challenges we have
in the modern era because social media
shows us
the highlight reel of everybody else's
life but we get to watch our own
failings from a front row seat right we
watch ourselves blunder through life
we realize just how far away from our
potential
we are but nobody else actually knows
that
no one else knows the podcast you could
have recorded the business that you
could have built
the book that you could have written in
a very very real sense you are only ever
competing against yourself
but because yes that's especially it's
absolutely right that's why the
individual
that that's exactly why group
categorization of people is so
dreadfully wrong it's like you really
are your only comparison group
especially as you get older
because your life is so idiosyncratic
and peculiar that
any compare i mean look you have to care
what other people think it's stupid to
think otherwise
be because you have to be social and you
have to be aware of what other people
are doing and all of that so
it's this is psychopathic individual
individuality
but it is genuinely true that no one has
your set
of opportunities and limitations
and so the the comparison just isn't
real it can't be sufficiently
multi-dimensional
you know because maybe you see someone
who's re i've dealt with i've
i've met many people who are very very
rich and
you can look at their lives and they
have these huge houses and
material plenty but j and they're
shielded from
many catastrophes that would hit someone
without those resources harder
but their lives are still full of
exactly the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and
so you you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see well the
person's
worked 80 hours a week for 40 years and
it's blown all his relationships out of
the water
it's like yes he's rich but he's also
old now
you know he's 60. and one of the best
predictors of wealth is age
you know really do you want to be young
and poor or old and rich
it's like i'd pick young and poor
because you can't buy youth
and so and and that's something that's
worth considering but you don't know
what burdens the people you're
jealous of are carrying
so leave it be
it's not it's not helpful to you to to
to be envious
i often tell people that we don't know
the price that you need to pay
to be the people that you admire so we
look at elon musk or conor mcgregor or
kim kardashian
and we want the success that they have
within a very narrowly defined domain of
competence
tiger woods fantastic example the
greatest golfer ever but
his dad mistreated him so much as a kid
that they had a safe word
they had a safe word like you do during
rough sex that tiger could tell him
if he'd had enough and it was called the
e word it was enough and tiger never
once said it
his dad would racially abuse him while
he was on the golf course telling him
that these white people are never going
to let you on here
but then when we look at tiger's golf
game
only then can we even begin to see what
kind of looks a bit
like child abuse but only when he's able
to perform in that way
but the question is would you pay that
price
to be tiger woods would you have
so little self belief outside of the
golf game that you have the most public
marriage failure that anyone's ever seen
he's on antipsychotic drugs and being
pulled over by police at the side of the
road
because he's fallen asleep at the wheel
he's spent
half a decade off the game because he's
been injured because of how hard he's
pushed himself
do you really want that because that's
the price you have to pay
to be tiger woods you can't just get the
golf capacity
without having everything that comes
with it this isn't pick and choose like
clothes off a rail
this is a wholesale sale you pick
everything warts and all
you need to pick their sleep patterns
their self-body image
all of the genetics they've got the way
that their brain feels when they go to
bed at night
a lot of people i think if they were
able to see the full package they
wouldn't pay that price
yeah and and that could well be the
right decision
no who who knows what price you pay for
hyper specialization
you know and i learned that looking at
you know
power mad c-suite types first of all
they're generally not power mad
because power is actually an
unbelievably unstable way of
establishing
authority you you get you get
slaughtered if you're not reciprocal in
most reasonably functioning
organizations
and if you're in an organization that
only rewards the
um exercise of power the probability
that that organization is going to fail
in totality is extraordinarily high
because it's a tyrannical organization
it'll lose touch with its customers
so the c-suite types um
they're they're working non-stop
corporate lawyers in new york you know
they make 700 an hour
but they work all the time all the time
and there are people who are suited for
that
but it isn't obvious that that's
for everyone or that it should be or
that it's even desirable
now it's a temperamental issue to a
large degree you know
many of those people are hyper
conscientious and so
if they they'll work whatever wherever
you put them what they would do is work
that's who they are and it's biological
as well
it's you know it's not all biological
because traits are affected by
learning and by environment in complex
ways but a huge chunk of it is
that you're born like that and that has
advantages and disadvantages
so conscientiousness is a good example
um
it's a good predictor of long-term life
success
but people are conscientious tend to
tear themselves apart if they become
unemployed for example
you know sometimes you get laid off you
worked hard but you get laid off
well people who are conscientious will
tear themselves into pieces
with guilt in that situation because
they tend to attribute
so much responsibility to themselves and
so there's a price to be
paid for conscientiousness it it opens
you up to a certain set of
vulnerabilities
so you know and you might be somewhat
unbearable to your family too because
all you ever do is work
you know you think well you you want to
be a good you want your father
maybe your husband perhaps your wife to
be a good provider
but you want them to do that at the
expense of everything else
generally no
talking about the price that we have to
pay do you think that having a deep
consciousness
and the ability to reflect on life is
really something that we
should be thankful for like is it a
blessing or a curse to feel everything
so deeply
it's both i think it's a blessing and a
curse
so i suppose it's it's
it the benefit it delivers is an
expanded scope of experience
and it's possible as well that
if it was done well it would be better
than anything but if it isn't done well
it's very very punishing
so i think you can make that case about
self-consciousness in people
i mean self-consciousness as a trait
loads on neuroticism
so you know and when people say i became
self-conscious
they usually mean they've become
embarrassed or anxious right
and those things do overlap to a
tremendous degree so self-consciousness
per se as an experienced phenomenon
is associated with negative emotion
well but do you want to dispense with it
well
no because it's really informative but
you don't want to experience it
so if you're made self-conscious by one
of your inadequacies
you want to remove the inadequacy you
don't want to remove the
self-consciousness
but i mean it can get out of hand too
you know people can be so self-conscious
and so self-critical that they can't
move forward
so it can definitely be
you can have too much of you can have
too much of that that's for sure
and it's it's one of the things you do
as a behavior therapist again a
cognitive behavior therapist is
if you have someone who's particularly
self-conscious
there'll be a litany in their head of
all of their
inadequacies and so it's like they have
an inner tormentor that just constantly
natters at them about how useless and
weak and
what inadequate they are and there's a
lot of stock arguments that repeat
and one of the things you do with
someone who is in that situation is you
have them write down
all their self-critical thoughts and you
do that
dialectically you know you help them
over many sessions
make a complete account and then you
help them develop counter arguments
not false counter arguments but you go
after it's like well is that
really true you know and here's the
here's the evidence that it's not
and so you can bolster people against
the
consequences of self-consciousness gone
amok
and that's often quite effective
when is that difficult where does that
voice tend to come from
well it's probably um
at least in part the inevitable
consequence of being
a creature who's continually being
socially evaluated
so you have a voice inside that
something like the
abstracted average of everyone's
criticism of everyone and that's useful
because
it reminds you not to do things that
other people are going to
object to it it also
assuming your culture is reasonably
functional it also reminds you
not to do things that are going to be
counterproductive
and so that's one source it's like
interiorized public opinion and then
other sources are well it's also the
voice of your ideals
and that so that in that sense you might
consider it your conscience
and that can be well that's
extraordinarily useful because it points
out your shortcomings
now one of the things i've
analyzed this the movie pinocchio sort
of ad nauseam i would say
but but it's been very useful to me um
one of the things so that's so
remarkable about that movie is that the
voice of the conscience which is
portrayed by jiminy cricket
is symbolically associated with jesus
christ in the movie
and
but interestingly enough
there's a dialectical relationship
between
the puppet the wooden headed puppet
whose strings are being pulled by
external forces
and the conscience so despite
the voice of the conscience being
symbolically associated with christ
the conscience has something to learn
during the journey as well
and so there's like a dialogue between
the conscience and the
developing individual and the
consequence of the dialogue is the
conscience
gets more effective as the person
becomes more developed
and i think that's right because imagine
that you have the average
ideal inside you speaking to you and you
have the
the average social voice inside you
speaking to you
but it isn't really speaking to you
it isn't taking your particularities
into account
and it isn't until you engage with your
conscience
that you can craft it into something
that's actually
speaking specifically to you
and then that's that's much less
burdensome and much more effective and
so and i i think that's
reasonable i because i don't think the
conscience
starts out infallible
i think we need to question our
assumptions far more than we think we
need to
around that there's so much of the
source code of what we're built upon
the stories that we were told as
children the beliefs that we've had and
built up around ourselves for a long
time
unless you actually take time away from
the urgent you never get onto the
important tasks
of thinking okay well i've held this
thing like a
like a bag like a satchel that i've
carried with me
for decades do i actually
is this serving me is there anything
even in here does this bag need to be
with me can i dispense with it
but if we're constantly and this links
back to the productivity conversation
if we're constantly chasing the urgent
forward focused
gaining and going and getting after it
we never actually
have the opportunity to sit back and
assess the foundations that everything's
built upon
if you're a building maintainer you
wouldn't build the building
and then never check on the foundations
i imagine they must have to do that
fairly regularly because that's what
the rest of the building is reliant on
to continue standing upright
there's an mba program at mcgill that's
targeted
to practicing managers
not not to mba students per se
and the man who runs it
has asked his students
what they found most useful about the
program and what they found most useful
was the opportunity to get away from the
day-to-day fires of their managerial
roles
and think about the long run
the medium to long run because what
happens with most managers is they're so
bit
busy putting out day-to-day fires that
they never
notice in what direction the entire
organization or the part their head
their heading
should be in what direction it should be
going
and we that's easy that's it's easy for
that to happen in our own lives
i mean i think that's actually why at
least part of the reason why
it's a real loss that people no so many
people no longer
attend church because you know when i
was a kid there was a lot of cynicism
and there still is about
you know one hour a week christians
they'd go to church and participate in
this
elevated ritual that was at least in
principle oriented towards a higher
mode of being and then promptly returned
to their
you know sinful work a day selves the
second they stepped out of church and
fair enough but an hour a week is a lot
more than zero
you know and you could object well most
people who were going to church weren't
engaging in this
foundational analysis it's like well
at least they were sort of doing it
and replacing that with zero doesn't
seem to be a very wise move
and so i guess that's it's sort of the
answer to your own question there too
though is you know you asked about the
utility of self-consciousness it's like
well
you can step back from your
the traps of your unthinking habits
and contemplate the whole
journey you know my colleagues and i
developed this
program online to help people do that to
write through their life
so it the past authoring program
helps people write an autobiography who
the hell am i
anyways and you think you know but you
don't
because you're complicated and then the
present authoring program helps you
identify your faults and
your virtues by your own definition
it's not imposed on you it's it's a
guided process of exploration and then
the future authoring program helps you
figure out
well if you could have what you wanted
what hypothetically what would that
actually be
and yes it's very much worth asking
yourself that question
because you're always searching for that
anyways even negatively because
your conscience will torment you for the
things you're not doing
okay while not doing in relationship to
what well in relationship to the
implicit ideal
of your conscience well what is that and
the answer is well you don't know
and so if you're just allowing yourself
to be tortured into submission
then you're at the mercy of some ideal
that
you don't know you don't and maybe you
wouldn't want to pursue if you actually
knew
you know that's why junk carl jung said
everyone lives out a myth but virtually
no one knows which what myth they're
living and maybe it's a tragedy
maybe you don't want it to be a tragedy
and then the question what do you want
that's a really deep question you know i
mean
you that's a serious question what is it
that you should value
and people say well being happy they
don't even mean that by the way if you
decompose what people mean
when they say they want to be happy what
it turns out they actually mean is they
don't want to be miserable
they're way more concerned with avoiding
suffering than they are with
pursuing you know enthusiastic positive
emotion
so even the the statement i want to be
happy
is actually not an accurate reflection
of what it is that you want
does that not show just how little of
our own motivations we get to see
we're so good at deception that we
deceive ourselves before we deceive
anybody else
we get to see this tiny tiny little
sliver of why we are here why we do the
things we do why we think the things we
think
i saw this quote today from robert
wright that said
emotions are the executioner of our
genes
or the executor of our genes all that
they're there is to just
enact what our biological imperative
wants and then we
get to glimpse them as they run past on
the way to doing a thing
and we believe that we're somehow we're
peering into the source code of our own
mind
that's not the case while we're
definitely not transparent to ourselves
by any stretch of the imagination we
wouldn't have to spend
decades studying psychology if we were
transparent
like we're we're tremendously mysterious
to
to ourselves i'm less pessimistic about
the executors of our genes because
i i think that you know
that that pessimistic biological
determinism
kind of the pessimism sort of stems from
this
assumption adoption of the assumption
that
our genes were tooled by a blind
watchmaker and there's this
deterministic soulless process at the
base of our biological being and
i don't buy that i think it's a lot more
complicated than that so i think
even if we are tools of our biology in
some sense
the ends at which our biology are aiming
are ethical
in in an unbelievably fundamental way
so and i think all the biological
sophisticated biological evidence
points in that direction i'll give you
an example so i was talking as i said to
the scientist yesterday richard tremblay
and he studies the development of
aggression and
it turns out that you don't learn to be
aggressive
that's there at the beginning you learn
how to control your aggression as you're
socialized
or not so but having said that
if you look at so the most aggressive
people are two-year-olds they're most
likely to kick
hit bite and steal and younger children
would also be likely to do that except
they're not
sophisticated enough in their behavior
to manage it
so it's not like six months old don't
experience rage but
all they can do is kick and scream so
but by the time you're two you can hit
someone and you do
but but 30
of children virtually never engage in
violent behavior
50 engage in some and about 17
do it habitually but all of them
do it less as they're socialized
there's a subsection that maintain it
quite
regularly and they tend to become
delinquents and criminals
so that's how it play okay but the
reason that's so relevant is that
you know there's this idea that's
rampant in our culture that our
hierarchical structures of authority are
predicated on power
but if that was the case the tendency to
aggression would be
universal among children not only
characterizing
you know a tiny minority and it would
increase with
socialization not decrease and so just
that evidence alone suggests that
however we organize ourselves in society
for success
it isn't the consequence of mutual
exploitation oppression
tyranny and subjugation those are
actually very ineffective strategies
they're only employed by people who
don't have the sophistication
to do things in a better way
and better would mean better for them as
individuals but also better for everyone
and so i firmly believe that your
oriented biologically towards a
very pronounced and sophisticated ethic
and so it's not so gloomy even if your
emotions are the handmaidens of your
genes which they are that that's that's
true
but i don't think that there's cause for
pessimism there
um we're we're
unbroken we're noble creatures
i like that talking about the beginning
of life there
and how we sort of come into this world
i want to talk about
the end for better or worse life is
short how can we add a sense of urgency
to it
well i i would say by reminding yourself
that life is short that's
that's that'll add a sense of urgency by
noticing
you know i calculated i don't know my
parents are
when my parents were in their 70s 60s
perhaps
i i usually saw them about once every
two years we communicate a lot more than
that but we live a long ways apart
so i calculated you know well my dad's
probably going to live till his mid 80s
or late
you know somewhere in there um and he's
six
he's 70 let's say i'm going to see him
40 more times
it's like okay 40 more times
that's urgent so you better get it right
because you don't have it you don't have
that many opportunities
you know it's the same when you're
formulating relationships in your
adolescence late adolescence in early
adulthood
you don't have that many experiments to
run
you know and you get you get old a lot
faster than you think
so attempt attention
attention attention is
an rated um faculty
it's not the same as thinking it's
watching
to see what's there in front of your
eyes and and to guide yourself as a
consequence of what you perceive
it's the it's the faculty that
transforms thought if you let it
so and your conscience alerts you as
well
tick tick tick you know you're wasting
time
and very few people are happy with that
some are burdened by it more than others
but virtually no one
escapes that voice of conscience
i suppose to some degree that's that's
the willingness not to
engage in self-deception chapter three
and beyond order is about that
people don't really repress the things
they don't want to face they just fail
to unpack them
you know like maybe you're on youtube
regularly and every time you shut the
computer off you feel somewhat disgusted
but you don't pay any attention to that
for a while for two years but then you
decide you're going to pay attention
then you find out well the reason you're
disgusted is because you're wasting your
life and you know it
and that disgust is indicating that but
unless you attend to the disgust and
unpack it
let it reveal itself as informative you
don't know what the message is you just
have a
sense of disquiet it's not easy to
transform that sense
of disquiet into an actionable plan and
often you have to talk to someone about
it as well
you have to discover so it's not like
you're repressing the emotion exactly
it's that you don't
undergo the difficult process necessary
to unpack it
it's effortful it comes back to that
assessing assumptions
that we said before if the goal of life
is to live a life which in retrospect we
are glad that we lived
it's important to give ourselves
perspective to develop that
metacognizance to step
away from the urgent to step away from
the phenomenological
day-to-day existence because the present
self is a petulant child
it's lazy and it wants the path of least
resistance and that glass of wine and
that new movie on netflix and the couch
looks really comfortable
very rarely does it yeah well that's the
danger with impulsive happiness is that
it does have that
present bound quality and in retrospect
that can lead to a life that's not well
lived
generally that yes yes yes
life definitely places philosophical
demands on you
whether you wanted to or not and so it
is useful to step back
i mean that's likely why the trait
openness
evolved that's the creativity dimension
that's the dimension that
that allows people to engage in
philosophical discourse and
to think laterally and it it does allow
you to
step back and look at things on a
broader scale
and to generate creative alternatives
the problem with examining your
assumptions is it's
very disquieting you know because
you want things to act the way
you predict and desire them to act and
you work within a set of axioms and you
act them out in order to maintain that
predictability that desirable
predictability
if you mess around the more fundamental
the axiom that you question
the more uncertainty you release
and some of that can be positive but a
plenty of it can be anxiety provoking i
mean just imagine that you're in a
relationship and
you know it's it's maybe a year into it
you haven't formalized and finalized it
but then
one day you allow yourself to ask the
question is this the relationship i want
to be in
well that's a fundamental question but
just imagine now you're destabilizing
your entire future
you're destabilizing your present you're
destabilizing your past
because while engaging in the
relationship you're acting out the
assumption that it's the proper
relationship but now you question that
that means
the story you told yourself about what
was happening while it happened
even though it's already happened was
wrong and
something else had happened and then you
have to think through what actually
happened so
it's unbelievably demanding and the more
axiomatic the assumption the more
certainty is cast into into troublesome
chaos
now you could say yeah but
the alternative is worse and i believe
that
often that's true but but the thing
about the alternative is that you can
always
forestall it right that question
tomorrow
you bet you bet and it's a very powerful
temptation
and no wonder you know do you want to
dig up the body now or do you want to
wait a month it's like well it'll be
more rotten in a month but
but it's not a month it's not now right
it's not now
and so i i understand why people don't
want to delve into things even if their
emotions indicate that they should
i mean i would see this all the time if
you're trying to settle an important
issue with your partner let's say
that can be a tremendously troublesome
excavation process and there's no
shortage of pain
but if you sort it out then
maybe things can be better doesn't mean
it's easy or
or or uh or pleasant quite the contrary
it's like surgery it's not it's like
surgery to remove something
you know that shouldn't be there it's
necessary but
man still surgery
i think it's possible to develop a
cathartic emotion
towards that i think it's possible to
down regulate the level of discomfort
that you feel when you do assess your
assumptions
on this show a lot of the time i try and
present uncomfortable truths
so insights that are accurate
but disquieting to learn and that to me
gradually exposing people and myself to
more and more of these and learning that
it's not an
existential threat it's not going to
destroy my ego
or learning or learning that it is an
existential threat but that you can
handle it
correct which is really what people
learn in
exposure therapy that's effective is the
thing they're afraid of
is frightening but they're tougher than
they think
and so and and that's very useful to
learn it
and yes i i do believe well it's also
the case that
if you decide that you're going to delve
into trouble as it rises
you're likely not to avoid the delving
process
more than necessary so the thing won't
grow into a monster that's quite so
large
you know and so once the relationship
you have with your
intimate partner is reasonably well
constituted
and you decide that you're going to
address problems as they arise
then it's less burdensome than
the total reconfiguration that might be
necessary before any of that has
has been has been started it's like
meant it's a form of mental hygiene i
would say in some sense
and so and you do get better at that
with practice
and um
you you perhaps you also get less likely
to jump to the worst possible negative
conclusion
you know so so and that's also useful
you don't catastrophize so
so much so
is there a rule which you didn't write
in the original list of 42
that you wish you'd put in there
oh set aside some time for play
that's probably that's one
um can i make a suggestion from your
work sure
it's from a lecture that you gave and
it's written on my wall over there
and it's don't practice what you do not
want to become
oh yes yes that's that's that's
that's uh
yeah i have a corollary of that too that
works in relationships
do not punish what you want to have
happen
so so here's an example imagine that you
that
that you've married someone that you
find attractive
and then imagine that other people find
that person attractive as well
and that that's actually somewhat
threatening to you
and then instead of dealing with the
fact that you're threatened by the very
thing that you were attracted to and
that you're blessed to have
you start to punish the person that
you're with
when they manifest themselves as
attractive
well you do that for 10 years and the
attractive person is no longer there
and then you're going to be angry at
them even though it was completely your
fault
you know because if you punish someone
for the manifestation of a desirable
virtue it really
hurts them and you because people are
you know it's so interesting to watch
what happens when people stop me on the
street
especially if they're shy and maybe
somewhat damaged
they want to tell me about something
good they've done
but they're very hesitant about it
because their experiences being that
if they reveal something good they've
done they either get ignored or punished
and so they don't want to do it they're
afraid but it
if they do it and then they get a reward
well they're they're unbelievably happy
about that
but that's a good example because it's
very common for people to experience
punishment for their virtue and you know
you can do that with your kids too if
you're jealous of them i mean maybe you
have a kid who's really bright he's
brighter than you
it's like are you so sure you're happy
about that
and how do you know that you're not
going to punish that child because
you're jealous
you know and if you think you're not
that sort of person well you should
think again because
people are that sort of people and
perhaps you can train yourself not to do
it but
envy is a pretty common human emotion
and the probability is that you're
reasonably prone to it
but so one of the things i learned again
from animal behaviorists
skinner in particular skinner believed
that
he's the psychologist who was most
famous for learning
experiments with rats he believed that
the best form of discipline
so if you want to train an animal to do
something was reward
you waited till the animal did something
that approximated what you wanted and
you immediately rewarded it so maybe he
would train a
rat to climb a ladder and then walk
across the top of a ladder down another
ladder and
well he he just watched the rat and
whenever the rat went near the ladder
he'd give it a food pellet and soon it
was near the ladder all the time
and then being near the ladder you know
it would put a leg on a front paw on one
rung
bang food pellet well soon the rat was
going like this
and then the next thing you know it was
going like this and he could i mean
a good animal behaviors can train an
animal to do an amazing thing
any number of amazing things in your
intimate relationships
if you watch the people that are around
you and then you see them doing
something that
they should do more of and i don't mean
this in a manipulative sense because
hopefully if you have any sense you're
rewarding them for something that would
also be really good for them
and you say look i saw you do this and
that's really good do more of that
it's like man you're just
opening up the pathway for that person
to deliver what you want if you'll admit
what you want if you'll reward it when
it happens if you pay proper attention
if you think you deserve what you desire
if you think your ideals are worth
pursuing if you have any faith in
yourself i mean all those things have
to be explored and answered but it's
unbelievably powerful
and that's all dependent on well moral
orientation and
the capacity to pay attention
absence of cynicism we have an
equivalent with ourselves as well right
the equivalent is definitely we need to
do what we want to become we can afford
to give ourselves those little rewards
and also to punish ourselves when we do
the things we don't want
and you oh well you see people people do
this all the time so
maybe uh you decide that you want to sit
down and write
oh hell i don't know maybe you decide
you want to clean your room
and it's a hell of a mess and you're
working with the therapist and
you know he says look just open one of
the drawers and
look at it because you've been avoiding
it for five years just
that's all you have to do this week open
it and look at it
and you know on the one hand that's so
trivial and it's pathetic
but on the other hand no it's not and so
often the person will come back and say
well that i did it but it was just
stupid
it's like no it wasn't
your room isn't clean but you opened the
damn drawer and now it's time to give
yourself a pat on the back
and but to do that you have to admit in
some sense you have to
admit how pathetic you actually are you
know you have to admit
how pathetic you are before you can
reward yourself
and that's okay because
that that patheticness well it's sort of
built in to your
to the fact that you're vulnerable you
know and you
need a small step and you need a reward
that's okay
it's okay that that's the case you know
when you see people what they'll do is
they'll say well that
you know that's just a good indication
of how useless i am
you know that that's all i could do
so they punish themselves well then you
have an opportunity you say to them look
there's two things going on
you can't clean up your room that's a
problem but you also can't reward
yourself
properly so we need to take that apart
and fix that
so that you can reward yourself properly
and that's also why you know
when i suggested to people that they
clean up the rooms the reason i did that
was because i actually knew how
difficult that is
because to get your room in order you
there's no way
you can get your surroundings in order
without simultaneously getting yourself
in order
at least to some degree and it's exact
for exactly the reasons i just discussed
what you'll find is the reason the mess
is
there is because of psychological mess
you know assuming it's not you didn't
just move or something you know what i
mean there might be obvious situational
contributors but generally speaking
is the mess the external mess is
absolutely isomorphic with the in
individual mess
and so it's really powerful to order and
beautify
something in your immediate environs
it's unbelievably powerful to do that
you learn a tremendous amount
you also may find for example maybe your
family is dysfunctional
and part of the reason that your room is
such a bloody mess is because if you
ever took any steps to address it
they would punish you because as soon as
you start to clean up your room then you
cast a dim
light on their mess and so they see you
taking a step forward they're going to
whack you because
now you're an ideal that's judging them
so
you deal with someone who is in a
dysfunctional family and you
ask them to do something positive to
move forward and then you watch
the resistances that emerge and you've
got a picture of the pathology in the
family
and that can help the person start to
sort that through
because maybe they can say it like you
have to do a lot of negotiating and
thinking before this is a possibility
but maybe you say well look you have to
have a talk with your mom
you have to say look mom i'm doing
something good here
and your reaction is to punish me
what the hell is up with that now
that's a complicated conversation and
maybe you have to start with something
even smaller than that but
you get the point you know these things
aren't simple
they're not simple at all and luckily
though they're right in front of you you
can in fact
do it and you'll learn a lot from doing
it
so i asked your colleague john viveki a
similar question
i asked about if you feel like you're
built for more
if you want to grow if you want to
improve if you want to become a better
human
but you don't have people around you
that also want to
you're scared that you're going to lose
friends you're scared that you're going
to be alone as you
start to go out on a journey of
self-improvement
how can people find the courage to do
that
well one thing they can do is
contemplate the consequences of not
doing it
you lose friends well
you're going to lose the friends who
don't want the best for you
those the friends you want in 10 years
i mean you lose friends well maybe you
gain new friends maybe gain better
friends
or maybe miracle of miracles your
friends
pick up their their mess too and move
forward maybe not and
i'm not i'm not naively optimistic about
such things
but you have to contemplate the price
you pay for inaction
and this is something i did with my
clients all the time it's like well
i don't want to change jobs well no
wonder
it's like you have to go put yourself
out to be interviewed
you have to send out 500 resumes you
have to be rejected
499 times you have to polish your
interview skills you have to update your
cv which means you have to take a
real look at the inadequacies in your
preparation
um and maybe you won't find a better job
it's like no wonder you're afraid of
that
okay you're in this job you hate and
it's 10 years from now
how does that look think about that
you already know you're in a little hell
you know perfectly well it's gonna get
worse
which is more frightening action or
inaction
well the thing about inaction is you're
blind to it eh
so you can hide from it well that's
chapter three again do not hide
things in the fog do not make the
assumption that inaction has no price
and so then you think i'm terrified of
this but i'm even more terrified of that
and you know people have asked me for
example
i suppose why i was willing or am
willing
to
engage in the troublesome process of
objecting when i think
something isn't going well
because i'm more afraid of the
consequences of
inappropriate silence it's not that i'm
brave
it's that i'm more terrified of the
alternative
so so i don't engage in the alternative
and i i don't know maybe i have a knack
for that to some degree maybe it's a
consequence of clinical training but you
know i can walk into people's houses and
look around and i think okay
there's something up here and i i mean
people have that ability
you know i walked into a house once and
and
the dishwasher was in the middle of the
kitchen and and it was
undone and had obviously been there for
a couple of weeks and the fridge
had food in it that shouldn't was no
longer food
and the cupboards had unopened wedding
gifts in them
like five years after the marriage i
thought there's a lot of things
in this household that are being swept
under the rug
and that was all laid out in in the
in the practical environs
it's like they hadn't negotiated who was
responsible for cleaning the fridge
they hadn't even been able to open their
wedding gifts it's like
something's rotten deeply so
and so i
i could see where that was headed
without a tremendous amount of effort
on the part of the p and it didn't work
they were divorced you know
a couple of years after that in a very
ugly manner for very
ugly reasons well i knew where that was
headed
you know and under different
circumstances i would have said
what the hell is that box doing there
oh you know it's nothing yeah no wrong
it's not nothing that's a little portal
to hell
i can see it and so could you if you
looked but you won't
and i mean that literally because people
won't look they'll walk into a room like
that
and they will not look at that thing
absolutely
and that's because if they look they'd
see
and they don't want to see and no wonder
but the consequence of blindness is
worse
it's it's worse i mean i have this
you know my family is would like some
peace
because i seem to be embroiled in one
thing after another and
you know they have a point
but peace is very hard to obtain
and i can't be blind to what i see in
the broader world around me
not if i see it if i see it it's like
there it is i'm gonna say something
you talk about heroes
and how they're they're called to do the
duty that only they can
because they can not because they're
willing the person that needs to go and
slay the dragon is the person who can
not the person who wants to look well
look
look here think about it this way like
some things
bug you and other things don't
i mean there's lots of things that could
bother you that don't because you're
obviously not bothered by
everything that you could be bothered by
right there's lots of things in the
world that aren't set right but some of
them really bug
you maybe they make you cynical and
bitter you know oh god look at how the
world is constituted it's so awful that
i can't
sustain my faith in the sight of that
it's like well you've got something to
do there
guy that's your problem why
who knows i would say the reason is that
it's your destiny calling to you in the
form of
guilt over unfulfilled obligations you
have an instinct for growth
that's not a mystical statement
it's part of being human we we don't
reach the limits of our potential
we're we're neotennic in some sense
we're continual children
biologically speaking uh and so we're
always
transforming and changing in some
direction
what direction well your conscience
tells you at least in part this bugs you
well
it's your problem now you may have to
investigate that and straighten it out
because even your formulation of what
bugs you
is likely to be ill-constituted
but still that's
that's something calling to you
and you you avoid it at your peril and
everyone else is
peril too and it is see that's the way
that your biology manifests itself in
such a sophisticated manner
it's beyond you it's like your better
self
is attempting to manifest itself by
torturing you with a set of problems
that you need to address
and then you can refuse that but
but then all the meaning goes out of
your life if you do that
that that's not good
we're developing something now to help
people turn problems into
goals
i have a problem well sure you do okay
what's your problem
okay well how do you turn that into a
goal so that's so interesting if you
think about
it that way is that that's your goals
your problems
what should i do with my life well what
problems do you have well there you go
solve those i'm not being flip about
this it's
it's that's where that's where the
answer is to be found that's not
happiness
and happiness has those problems you've
already described you know it's it's got
this
now focused impulsivity
and and you know i've been hard on
happiness as a pursuit and perhaps too
much so because
i haven't had very much happiness
because i've been so ill for the last
while
and you know i i it's
possible that i've undervalued it
perhaps not but
it's possible in any case if it comes
along you're a fool if you don't welcome
it but
but it's still not the proper pursuit
i suppose to some degree it's not deep
enough
well if the thing if the thing that's
pulled you through over the last
18 months to two years has been meaning
and purpose and something
less ephemeral and less fleeting and
grander and
more written into the source code of
your being than happiness then i think
it's a
as lifeboat it's been love too it's been
loved too
you know it's been responsibility for
sure but it's definitely been loved
a lot of people have taken taken care of
me and
i also wanted to be around them i wanted
to be around
because i loved them so
and i think that's why the second book
has a more communitarian
element too because
so many people have been so helpful and
also because i've seen even more clearly
how much
of what sustaining is derived from love
love and duty that's pretty good i mean
duty in some sense is the cool
equivalent of love it's it's
it's it's it's love shorn of its
warmth it's what you should do and it's
necessary and and there is tremendous
meaning to be found in that but
but love has this
maternal ah comfort
and warmth that beauty locks
it feels like judy is pushed from the
back whereas love is pulled from the
front
love pulls you forwards whereas duty can
kind of push you
sure i mean you it's not unreasonable to
say that love entices
i don't think duty entices duty might
torment
and love entices so
what's next i know that it's not another
book
that's got rules in i know that you've
said that 24 out of 42
and beyond order 12 more rules for knife
is going to be the final rules
book are you thinking about writing
something else or is it
are you focused on the point i'm writing
i'm writing
no i'm writing um i'm my i have about
three or four functional hours in a day
now
the rest of the day is pretty much
preparation so that those hours can be
functional
but that's expanding and as it's
expanding i'm starting to feel the
the spaces that are opening with writing
and
i'm going to write it looks like i'm
going to write a series of essays
on topics that are of crucial importance
to me
at least and um and i've started doing
that so
tentatively it's something like 24
topics worth considering
i don't know if i seem to be attracted
to you know increments of a dozen
but um well 12 is a magic number because
it's divisible by one two three four and
six you know
so there's something about it that's
kind of magical but and i don't know if
if it's 24s they'll be shorter and i
kind of like to experiment with that you
know
something that would be more like a 10
or 15 minute read that would be really
concise
uh i don't know if i can do that that's
the goal at the moment is to write
another book that's 24.
i'm going to focus on 24 questions or
issues that i think are
they're compelling to me and and they're
sort of they're at the forefront of my
thinking
so it might be fun and nice for you as
well to have
something that's a tiny little bit more
there's boundaries between the topics
that you're able to go very hard and
deep but within a
constraint and then we can do it again
and we can look at this i think
with beyond order though that's the
advantage of trying to make it short
yep and there's a unifying theme right
everything in here had to be about order
everything in the first book had to be
about chaos
i think that'll be that'll be a good use
of your time and given the fact that you
are
strapped for time i'm very appreciative
that you've joined me today i'm a
massive
massive fan you have been a huge huge
influence
on where i've got to now and
i think it wouldn't be too extreme
to say that you don't understand the
magnitude of the impact that you've had
on people because
you can't see how the impact you've had
on people has had their impact on others
you are degrees of separation removed
from an undeniably better world as far
as i can see it
yes and so is everyone else
yeah i mean you can be woken up to that
and then i can tell you something about
that because i do understand it to some
degree i think
because people constantly approach me
and i see
because i watch but i can tell you as
well that there is nothing that's
that's it's so gratifying
that it's almost too much you know and
it's a funny thing because you could say
well what if you could have everything
you wanted
and then the next question is do you
really think you could stand that
and so you know i'm in this unbelievably
fortunate circumstance
where people tell me
about the steps they've taken
to make their lives better
in wonderment and they allow me to see
that
and it's it's very intimate you know and
it's it's stunned it's stunning i'm
walking with a friend of mine
quite regularly and he's a tough guy man
he he's worked with delinquents his
whole life so
he's he's like a social worker superhero
uh very physically tough person and a
very masculine
male but a social worker and very caring
and he's been very helpful to me and
he's been walking with me every day and
people are stopping me and you know
the other day this guy walked by us on
the street and he was pretty run down
he's probably in his mid 40s and
he's kind of street person looking you
know
and he stopped and he looked at me and
he came over and he said
i love you and i walked away and my
friend said
you sure have a lot of men coming up to
you and saying that they love you
yeah i mean i don't know i just don't
know what to make of it it's so
the behavior is so completely
unusual and you know my wife too she
said she's seen a whole different side
of men
especially since we started touring
because of this happening because
generally when people approach me and
they're not invariably men but they
probably are
70 of the time they're very polite
and and very careful and
she said that's showed her a whole side
of men that she didn't even know existed
and so it's it's it's
something but i do believe that people
you know it i do believe that
my experience has been that
there isn't anything that i
guess two things there isn't anything
that's
more rewarding than trying to do things
right
all other forms of reward pale by
comparison
they're not even in the same conceptual
universe
and there's nothing that's more
adventurous
than telling the truth you have no
idea what will happen to you if you tell
the truth
and so if you're looking for an
adventure a boy
that's an adventure
you've said that sometimes you feel
ashamed because you don't feel worthy of
being
some sort of sage at the head of a
movement of people that are sorting
their lives out
but in the nicest way possible you
don't get to choose if people follow you
we
chose you like as the prototypical
27 year old directionless guy that
stumbled onto your work
something in you spoke to something in
me you taught me the value of telling
the truth and if being responsible and
of doing what is right and
what is easy it was like um it was like
a pebble
at the top of an intellectual awakening
avalanche it was like a like a gateway
drug to integrity
and it's not just me that's got better
the world is undeniably a better place
because of the sort of person that i've
become i'm a better
friend i'm a better son i'm a better
boss i'm a better partner
i've had the fortune of reaching tens of
millions of people on this podcast and
i've given tedx talks and i've improved
the texture of my own daily existence
because of the process that your work
triggered
you do not know the depth of impact that
your work has had
and if the option had been there i
and probably a lot of other people would
have happily taken on our share of your
suffering
over the last year if it would have
somehow helped as a thank you for how
you've helped us
so thank you
it looks to me like you are doing that
from everything you just said
so you know hooray great
that that's exactly how to do it and
and it's a privilege to be uh involved
in
in this and you know god only knows what
the consequences will be
so you know we'll aim high
and work hard and speak carefully
and be appreciative and all of that and
then we'll see what happens
jointly jordan peterson ladies and
gentlemen beyond order
will be linked in the show notes below
and i'm looking forward to seeing
what the next few months holds to
reiterate what i said at the start i'm
very very glad that you're back
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace
you